es ist der dunkelste ort der ukraine der
kessel von mario pohl seit wochen ist
die hafenstadt die etwa so groß wie
duisburg ist von der außenwelt
abgeschnitten russische truppen haben
die stadt eingekesselt bombardieren
wohngebiete und sogar flüchtlingstrecks
einigen gelangen die flucht mit ihnen
hat unser bild reporter philipp potthoff
gesprochen ich stehe hier vor dem
bahnhof in lemberg wo täglich hunderte
oder tausende menschen an kommen aus
allen teilen der ukraine in diesen tagen
kommen vor allem viele menschen aus dem
kessel von mario pohl der stadt an der
küste am asowschen meer die seit wochen
von den russischen truppen belagert wird
eingekesselt ist und von der außenwelt
abgeschnitten und man trifft hier
menschen mit den verschiedensten
geschichten menschen wie ein
hockeyspieler der glück hatte weil er am
februar mit seiner mannschaft mario pohl
verließ um zu einem auswärtsspiel zu
fahren und dann nicht eingekesselt wurde
aber auch er sorgt sich um seine mutter
und man trifft hier auch familien
die eingekesselt wurden die wochenlang
im bunker saßen wochen lang beschossen
wurden menschen sterben sahen und jetzt
endlich hier angekommen sind und zum
ersten mal seit wochen sich in
sicherheit fühlen in mario pohl kann man
nichts mehr kaufen
die geschäfte haben alle geschlafen
alles hat geschlossen es gibt keine
verbindung nach außen
man weiß nicht was in der ukraine
passiert ob es einen sinn geht mario
pohl zu verlassen man weiß nicht wie die
lage in der gesamten ukraine
menschen die überhaupt per netz haben
denken ist es in der ganzen ukraine
genauso
es ist alles sehr schwer ich mache mir
um die anderen bewohner von mario pohl
sehr große sorgen sie haben kein essen
kein wasser es ist sogar sehr schwer
wasserholen zu gehen weil wir menschen
dabei beschossen werden und sterben wir
hatten keine luftschutzkeller ich hatte
angst verschüttet zu werden unser haus
neben einem hügel da waren wir sehr
lange und vielleicht steht das haus noch
immer das letzte mittel das
der horror von mario pohl der kreml
fordert die stadt zur kapitulation auf
am montag läuft das ultimatum aus wer
noch in der stadt geblieben ist wird vom
russischen militär als nazi und bandit
betrachtet es droht eine
vernichtungswille wie sie selbst mario
pohl noch nicht erlebt hat doch das
ukrainische militär die ukraine halten
dagegen sie kämpfen für ihr land ihre
freiheit ihr leben ich danke diesen
jungs ich bin sehr sehr stolz auf aber
ich mache mir auch große sorgen ich will
dass fliehen ich bin dagegen dass die
menschen sterben müssen ich will dass es
überall ruhig und still und schön ist
und unsere kinder glücklich und gesund
aufwachsen
er entkam der kriegsherren mario pohl
nur durch einen zufall hockeyspieler
alexander
so dass ein stück des haben alina und
hat uns gesagt dass die meisterschaft
vorbei ist und
wir haben uns entschlossen
[Musik]
nicht mehr
und man kann auch
dass mein haus um ja nicht
in mario pohl sind hunderttausende
zivilisten eingekesselt laut berichten
sind bis zu 90 prozent der wohnungen
zerstört die stadt komplett in schutt
und asche ein trümmerfeld verantwortet
von krimml diktator wladimir putin er
lässt schulen kindergärten und theater
mit bestialischer brutalität
bombardieren die wasser und
stromversorgung gekappt heizungen gehen
nicht mehr medikamentenlieferungen gibt
es nicht das traurige schicksal seiner
mutter ja meine mutter ist
aber es ist nicht möglich
der kampf um mario pohl putin will die
stadt um jeden preis ein es könnte noch
wochen dauern
[Musik]